[Music]
sonic the hedgehog
you're no match for me
this is the moment to be the big hero
oh great the winter soldiers
it is my destiny to destroy you
work smarter not harder
that wasn't too bad
sonic the hedgehog 2 april 8th and here
we go
get your heart out
papa's got a brand new stash
oh there are two of them now
you're never going to get my power
do i look like i need your power
sonic the hedgehog 2
quick stretch little snack
on april 8th
time to go for a ride
the wheel competition
begins
sonic
meet knuckles
this is what we're gonna do step one
light taunting step two i have no idea
i just got goose bumps
sonic the hedgehog 2 in theaters april
8.
[Music]
quick stretch little snack and here we
go
sonic i love that you want to help make
a difference
but you're being reckless don't worry
nobody's gonna get hurt
pretending to be batman blue justice
trademark pending
you're still just a kid
trust me there will come a moment when
your powers will be needed
but you don't choose that moment that
moment chooses you i just got goosebumps
wait a second did you steal that from
oprah
papa's got a brand new stash
since i've been gone i've discovered the
source of ultimate power
that sounds big
it's been on my vision board for
hope i'm years too late
i'm sorry who are you
tails okay this is what we're gonna do
step one light taunting step two i have
no idea
[Music]
that wasn't too bad
today's forecast calls for a 100 chance
of adventure
[Music]
return to sender
face it you're never going to get my
power
do i look like i need your power
where
are my manners sonic meet knuckles
[Music]
[Music]
so